So why do we care about a variation
in a protein or enzyme called Tyrosinase? With Tyrosinase
is the rate limiting step in the production
of melanin. There are many steps to making the
pigment in melanin. And some of the first
are converting a molecule called Tyrosine. Actually Tyrosine, the
very amino acid we've learned about and is
in our amino acid alphabet, into another molecule called
dopa, and from dopa into dopaquinone. Tyrosinase
performs this function, but it's pretty slow,
actually. Compared to all the other steps you need to get melanin. This is the
part that takes the longest. So this
single nucleotide variation up here. The cytosine to
an adenine. The change in amino acid
from serine to tyrosine, ironically enough, causes, right,
that's a missense mutation now. Which causes Tyrosinase to work 40 to
50% slower than it normally does. So if this is true
we would expect to see a decrease in overall melanin because we're going to make
it a lot slower. If we have less melanin
we're going to have lighter skin. If we have lighter skin,
we're going to have UV rays that are able to
get into the cells. So that they can simulate vitamin
D production. So this particular mutation will give
you lighter skin. Where as this sequence promotes darker
skin. Now there are actually several other genes
that affect skin pigmentation and they all have multiple
alleles that explain all kinds of intermediate pigmentation
as well as red haired individuals. But this is
just one example of how a single nucleotide
variation in the coding region, causing a missense mutation
from a Serine to Tyrosine, slows the enzymes
function by 40 or 50%, allowing for less
pigment in the skin, thus letting more sunlight
in. To produce vitamin D. Of course the
flip side of this is the more sunlight you let in the more risk you are
for DNA damage. And that's why light-skinned people
when they're in really UV intense regions are much
higher risk for skin cancer than dark pigmented people. Let's go talk to
somebody who knows quite a bit about living in hot, UV rich equatorial regions.